hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from round
eight of the alt box norway chess
tournament 2020
a battle of the norwegians in this round
on the wide end magnus carlson and he's
paired against aryantari
so let's hop right to it carlson opening
with e4
atari replying with e5 we have a roy
lopez
to be a bit more exact it's a closed
system carlson's
uh quite fond of the d3 move he's played
it many times now
e4 is now secure and because of this
there's now a threat to take the knight
and take on e5
black defends against that and secures
his e-pawn
threatening to now hunt the bishop
that's addressed there's a square for
the bishop
bishop d7 some prep work for
central expansion knight a5 hits
and this time there's two options now
that c3 is in
backs up to a2 computer likes c2 staying
trained on a4
in a spot to immediately recapture
should black pull the trigger on that
move
this is a suggestion for many moves
in this game if black takes this pawn
first of all there's no guarantee black
gets to hang on to it
black is also taking away from the
center that's anti-positional
c4 is a the big square that's given up
you can see a knight leaping in there
soon
if white wants to regain the pawn he can
invest these tempe
in there and pick up the pawn like that
after the smoke clears what can we say
a6 isn't too bright
it's isolated and will likely be a big
target for the white pieces
so what does black play it's the opening
you have to get castled right
c5 okay
why not castles well if castles there's
b4
and after knight c6 this pawn isn't
having too much fun
can't move so
on this move 10 black
makes sure he gets the move in that
white has the potential to
stop white cannot stop
castles castles can wait
c5 first so this pawn's voice will be
heard it will have
an influence on the center at the same
time
notice the d5 square it's a hole in
black's cam
and is a big focal point for the rest of
this game
ideally what would white like to have
happen
a knight on the d5 square against a bad
bishop
this guy in e7 bishop
g5 is a step in that direction a step
towards realizing that scenario
white wants to eliminate the pieces that
can control the d5 square i'm not just
talking about any pieces
i'm talking about the minor pieces in
particular
both knights and the light square bishop
are the ones that can control
d5 okay
black castles only now knight d2
is met with next rook b8 so once more
black can take on a4 and this may turn
out to
be upon white cannot so easily regain
you'll notice in this position now that
the bishop is on g5
it's not around to watch over b2 it can
be quite a convenient
defender when it's still on that home
square
black can put some pressure on it so
this can cause white
some inconvenience it might not be so
smooth
in regaining uh it may not be so smooth
for white to regain the a4 pawn
okay black never goes forward with that
capture
rook b8 it is things seem to flow a bit
more
um natural not taking away from the
center
after rook to b8 a takes b
only after the rook has abandoned the a
file white white
takes on b5 notice the timing right
aha i have this file all to myself
okay from here it's rookie one
typical reposition for this queen knight
the second ranked
knight needs some work it's not happy
on the second rank black follows up with
b form this move
is making it easier
for white to one day realize this
good night versus bad bishop
scenario these nights
are going to be exchanged in a blink now
c4 is opened up and we'll just be
moments away from a light square bishop
exchange and this can happen
at any point so
a different idea and i'm touching on a
different idea here
because soon and by soon i mean move 20
black is kind of in a position where
he kind of shuffles and
yeah the character of the position there
there's no longer
good moments to change the character of
the position
a suggestion here for black is to play
knight
c6 and not give up that c4 square after
knight c6
or if knight c6 was played instead of b4
if white continues on this path to pivot
on f1
black can look forward to maybe an idea
like this saying
let's trade my bad bishop for your good
bishop i want to keep this guy around
to watch over the d5 square
so something like this the knight can
return
and black has a strong defender of this
weakened d5 square
if we consider a different move
let's say instead of knight f1 white
says oh i'm gonna swipe the knight while
i have the chance
and then play here well
now we have this as a way to at least
provide
some cover for the d5
square so these are some different
imbalances that we can
see for black or these are some
different
paths black can choose in order to help
remedy the weakened d5 square
okay in this game c4
the knights are exchanged the b file is
completely opened
the rooks are both connected and the
light square bishops
are exchanged
uh this was kind of awkward for me to
see
black kind of make it a little bit
easier for
white to have the strong knight versus
bad bishop position
but then again this guy is standing
pretty good
um opposite the king again this is
probably always going to be a focal
point f7
it's a strong piece black is looking to
get rid of it
so bishop b5 it is
the exchange is welcome another exchange
on board
many steps have been taken to
uh take advantage of this weekend d5
square
at this point it's just a matter of
throwing the knight there
it takes four moves
that's step one of four
get some moves in here uh this one right
here
bishop to e7 i
i thought well if white is looking to
one day get into that d5 square
isn't this an idea you watch over e3
it does stop knight e3 but
this this square has some pressure on it
so what what does this
knight post on c4 it's not just about a
knight on d5 a knight on c4 is excellent
as well if bishop is playing here
stopping the knight
this queen is constantly having to
defend d6
so that's an inconvenience for black
it's going to be awkward one way or
another because of this pesky knight
he's a real powerhouse in this game
from this point on whether on c4 or d5
so with bishop to e7 what can we say
black is allocating the bishop to
the d6 pawn the bishop is responsible
for defending
that point the least valuable piece in
the position watches over this guy
all right flight square for white
some a flight square for black some
small improvements
on white side king g2
queen on f3 she is excellently placed
on f3 safeguarding the king
should there be some attack against the
white king it's difficult to see
how an attack even surfaces
against the white king excellently
placed here
good defender if need be for the white
king
uh she is more so in my opinion seen
as an offensive piece from f3
raking this uh f file
f7 and f6 will soon be
uh we'll see white start to connect
on those squares this position it's a
classic
good knight versus bad bishop something
you'd see
uh in a chest book uh
under this strategic topics
all right let's see how things follow up
here white has to
babysit a little bit c3
from here queen e6 this rook is very
active
black neutralizes it one rook is
exchanged
open file for white the bishop is pinned
and black is out of the pin king g7
and from here knight to e3
so angling for the d5 square it's a
difficult position for black
but there is still hope
uh this is black's last
chance to find some way to
neutralize the knight when it's on the
d5 square
the move played in the game is rook c7
and it's lost for black after that move
the best move in this position is queen
to d7
and after knight d5
bishop to e7 i had a look at
rook to a7 i thought initially one of
the ideas with queen d7 was to con
continually attack this rook and you
know if he goes here
some some idea like this eventually
forcing some repetition or the rooks
have to be exchanged
um that would not be a good idea
for black in this position after knight
d5 if black follows with rook
a7 it's a checkmate in four
kicking off with queen f6
and well we can have this
as a checkmate sequence so
no rook a7
this is the best defense for black queen
d7
and knight e7 first controlling f6
and then let's say after h4 now black
can
try to eliminate the rook something like
this repetition or the rooks are
exchanged
i believe what i'm getting to here
is that this right here is the best
uh black can hope for to
work with the queen and bishop versus
queen and knight
as we will soon see the white rook is
a huge pest constantly observing either
the seventh or eighth rank
and black is not able to neutralize it
and when you combine that with the
powerful knight
on the d5 square it's simply
overwhelming
for black's position so this was the
last
chance for black needed to play queen d7
bishop e7 and then try and get the rooks
off
okay rook c7 was played
knight d5 queen eriksen rook c8
whenever this offer of an exchange is
there white simply ducks it
no way i have an active rook you have a
passive rook you're in a closed file
play follows with rook to b8 if black
tries to change the structure with c4
that's no problem we can take
many times this is seen as a success
for black these pawns are now accessible
to the rook
but e4 is secure and this knight
says yeah i have seats recovered no
problem
so no great progress is made
if black goes with c4 rook b8 in this
game
and i'll throw a pop quiz your way
white to move what do you think carlson
plays
next what would be your plan at this
stage
for white what's your move feel free to
pause the video
okay the move is
h3 a baby move
one little step with the pawn uh
there isn't a way to improve
the rook the knight the queen
no king move is going to be any good no
pawn moves are really helping over here
h3 is looking to one day
establish a pawn on the g5 square
yg5 well that's where we start to see
many of the white pieces intersecting we
already have the queen and knight
get a pawn there and all of a sudden the
knight is ready to jump
towards the king okay
after h3 it's rook d8 g4
rook d7 it's declined
rook to a8 and now we have
f6 so another move
you know black knows that this is this
is happening soon so
is are there ways to stop it not really
if you play g5 this knight's
eyes light up he's already happy about
having the d5 square he'll be even
happier
getting to f5 with check
okay so g5 wouldn't be good what about
bishop e7
is that interfering with g5 well
yeah but now you're in a giant pickle
how are you untangling you're not
nearby there's queen h3 and look out
made on h8 so bishop e7 is not going to
help
f6 is tried g5 anyway
this pawn is pinned to the f-file
queen takes f8 so f5 is tried
the queen is no longer seeing h3
queen h3 i like to pause at this moment
and point out some things about this
position
that i think can be useful
uh for those of you who may be looking
to improve your game
i want you to consider a couple things
here a couple components of this
position
consider first the white position
and take stock of what
black pieces or pawns are in white's
house
and what intersection
squares there are in white's house where
do
two or more black pieces or pawns
converge well the first
component black pieces in white's house
doesn't exist
simple enough intersection squares
there's one on d4
considering now black side
uh just drawing some lines in here first
of all we can look at
well we have what pieces are pawns in
black's house we have a pawn
a knight and a rook and looking at the
intersection squares we have
f6 we also have
h6 and we can also identify
the h8 square even though the rook isn't
seeing it directly
we can say that the bishop is pinned so
black is
seriously restricted it is it is as if
black is only playing on three ranks
in this position and is completely tied
up
many of these intersection squares are
made use of in this final combination
by carlson white is clearly
in the driver's seat okay
the threat here by the way is to play to
h6
and next win the bishop so with black's
next move
he defends against that secures the
bishop
and one more pop quiz what is carlson's
next
move feel free to pause the video
okay here we go there are many wins this
is the flashy one
the one tactic in this game this move
42 made possible
in large part because of all of these
positional
advantages positional pluses that
white has accumulated the move played
rook to e8 looking to distract the queen
from her defense of g6
queen takes rook follows queen enters on
h6 with check g6
with check there are only three legal
moves now
white's down a rook but has a winning
attack
with the queen and this powerhouse
knight power horse is ready to jump in
what does black play
if you block with the rook you drop the
queen
if you block with the bishop you're also
going to drop the queen
knight f6 exploiting this pin
if rook takes knight queen takes queen
queen check and a queen combined with
two connected past pawns on the fifth
are too much
for black to handle
the third option is the move played in
the game king h8
but after knight f6 black resigns
what do you do white's threatening mate
on g8
and also to simply take the queen
no good solution for black
take the knight again you lose the queen
and you're gonna lose one of these two
next
no good solution here we don't even take
the queen after bishop g7
that would be mate queen and knight are
too much
so uh let's have a look at
one photo here courtesy of lenar otis
capturing this final moment arientari
stopping the clock he's had enough
and he resigned knows that there's no
good solution here
so let's have a look at
the tail of the tape on this one
here we go so
what can we say here after knight to
beat knight b to d2
that's where it was suggesting b takes
a4 maybe one of the better moments to
play that anti-positional taking away
from the center
black is up a pawn but squares are given
up
instead it was rook to b8
and the other key moment this really
doesn't show up so much on this graph
you know it goes from the 0.5 and then
after b4
it goes to 0.7 but this was really a
serious
like something else i was pointing out
knight c6 instead
trying to arrive at a different minor
piece setup
giving up that c4 square made life again
a lot more
easy for white to realize one day
a a really strong knight versus bad
bishop
position and then finally even though
black was in that difficult spot trying
to defend with that
uh really bad bishop tall pawn there was
one chance for maybe a regrouping
after knight to e3 rook c7 and then
there it was completely lost
he had to try at that point uh queen d7
bishop e7
and it's just a growing advantage from
there
at the end of the day what do we have
average centipond loss for carlson
11 to atari's
32. okay
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you